this video is brought to you by gentian
impact I legit never thought this day
would come yet here we are about to
review Dragon Ball GT while I have made
Dragon Ball GT something of a running
joke over the last while as a bit of
lighthearted fun there's always been an
element of truth to it when the original
series ended way back when I was a kid
like many others my age I quickly
shifted to Dragon Ball GT thinking it
would be more of what I loved about
Dragon Ball Z and at the time it wasn't
I say at the time because right now I
want to review this show as fairly as I
possibly can I haven't seen Dragon Ball
GT in maybe 15 years and I have changed
considerably since then the strong but
negative feelings I had for Dragon Ball
GT have much like its relevance in the
modern Dragon Ball and anime landscape
faded with time and at present I don't
really recall much of the story and my
feelings towards it are about as neutral
as they ever have been so what better
time to dive head first into the show
that ended it all for me when I was a
young teenager a show that pushed me
away frustrated me Beyond belief and
admittedly moved me to tears this is my
review of the infamous and intensely
controversial Dragon Ball GT part one
the black star dragon balls
Dragon Ball GT isn't really divided into
clean sections like Dragon Ball super
was so I've decided to follow the arcs
as they are defined in the fandom the
first Arc being the Black Star Dragon
Ball Saga that flows from episodes 1
through to 16. and I want to make
something clear here from the get-go
having just finished watching these it's
not gonna be pretty so if you're a fan
of this Arc I'll try to be fair and
explain where my issues are and why so
without further Ado let's get into it
the story itself kicks off as Goku
finishes up his training with Ube and
then sends him on his way I guess the
ending of Dragon Ball Z wasn't worth
following up on and oob wasn't worth
exploring right now this honestly
doesn't bother me too much but really
reinforces the notion that Goku's
decision to go off for a decade training
Ube was a bit of a waste of time or at
least this is the message the show is
sending us right now a little bit later
the peel off gang make it to the lookout
somehow and discover the black star
dragon balls you know just sitting there
out in the open you know the dragon
balls that have earth-shattering
ramifications if used the dragon itself
when summoned is probably the most
visually impressive spectacle from this
Arc however Goku interrupts pilaf as he
kinda sort of wishes Goku was a kid
again I mean he sort of says it but not
really I'm not really sure what counts
as a wish anymore but we gotta get the
plot moving somehow I guess and it sure
is a good thing that Goku's clothes
became a kid with him too once pilaf
finishes using these balls to turn Goku
into a little kid again the balls then
disperse throughout the Universe and
that's when we hear that the Earth will
be be destroyed in exactly one year from
when the wish was made if the balls are
not gathered again now this is where the
show loses me even more I have no
earthly idea how these balls really work
I mean I would assume like the other
dragon balls they would have turned to
stone along with the other balls once
the old Guardian had passed also why
would their creator have made them to
scatter Across the Universe how would he
the creator of these Dragon Balls have
been able to gather them see because
there was no other way to get off of
Earth at the time also I have no idea
why there's a one-year time limit and a
consequence of not meeting that time
limit too it seems really arbitrary only
there to provide incentive for Goku who
up until this bombshell hit was rather
indifferent to being young again or to
even collect the Dragon Balls again in
the first place I get the dragon balls
in this show are a McGuffin used to make
the story work but they didn't need to
be dragon balls in this instance they're
already different enough to Warrant
being their own thing tying them two
objects within a show that has already
so many rules to abide by makes things
needlessly difficult to work with that
said the rest of the episode is spent
reintroducing all characters that we
won't see for the rest of the arc and
most importantly the character of pan
someone we will be spending a lot of
time with episode 2 is the first episode
where we will see the pace the series
will be moving at glacial Pace there's
no sense of urgency and the decisions
that are made seem excessively juvenile
Goku says that they should use the
regular Earth's Dragon Balls to relocate
themselves to the dragon balls in space
but I say that's pretty dumb why not
just wish them to Earth did I just make
the entire Arc pointless the vast
majority of this episode covers very
filler-centric stuff like Goku getting
kidnapped pan pouting over not being let
go and Trunks goofing off of work
additionally no one seems to be taking
this thing with the balls seriously
other than Gohan Chichi and Bulma in
reality the most capable people should
go on this life-threatening trip not the
children as a form of discipline also
Vegeta has a mustache I just needed to
say that pan then sneaks out onto the
ship before blasting off and is now part
of the party Goku Trunks and pan blast
off into space at this point in my watch
through I really like that pan had a
reason for leaving to prove her maturity
and Independence and in addition to this
motivation has a strong personality it's
not exactly a unique character type or
unique personality but she fills the
role well of an immature kid trying to
be strong like her relatives I'm gonna
try to go through the episodes faster
now because they get really bad episode
3 begins and they land on Omega and all
of a sudden it feels like Star Wars this
subplot seems to ignoring the dragon
balls that they literally just left to
retrieve almost immediately after
leaving Earth in order to deal with this
planet that shakes people down for money
we then get introduced to Gil a little
robot that now acts as the group's
Dragon radar episode 4 begins and yes
there is a part two to this story and
trust me I've already glazed over a ton
of stuff that really has no consequence
within the story their ship gets
confiscated and the need to retrieve it
from this weird alien dictator guy Goku
can use Instant Transmission because
plot needs to happen and some random guy
with big ears appears and knows that
Goku is a Saiyan somehow based
exclusively on his Kamehameha an
earth-learned technique and yes now two
episodes deep into this God forsaken
subplot they are still on this damn
planet and there's more by the time the
third episode in this mini Arc comes
around I noticed that an absurd amount
of time has been spent not Gathering the
dragon balls you know the balls that if
you don't gather them will bring about
the Earth's destruction somehow rijiv
the big-eared alien guy that recognized
Goku as a Saiyan begins to fight Goku
it's a really short fight but honestly
it's fine it's definitely the best part
of the show so far but was only like two
minutes long I didn't really care about
the fight I don't care about red jiv but
it was better than looking at like 95
percent of what the show has put in
front of me so far my issue with this
mini Arc within this Saga I'm watching
can be summed up in one word pointless
the last three episodes could be removed
entirely and the only thing that will be
lost is the little robot guy and he
could have been introduced or
incorporated into the story in a bunch
of other ways we didn't learn anything
new about men or trunks or Goku from
this story's inclusion
sipso's deep in
the deepest one so far they land the
land planet where everything is like
Earth except giant Pang is taken by a
bunch of bees for most of the episode
and a giant accidentally takes the
Dragon Ball and lodges it in its tooth
pan gets rescued and Goku retrieves the
ball by being the Giant's dentist none
of this is important the only thing you
need to know is that they have one
Dragon Ball now next the next two
episodes yes two are spent within a mini
Arc again fun the story itself revolves
around this Village that are seemingly
being tormented by this fat ugly
annoying catfish monster a monster that
claims to cause earthquakes in order to
not anger the Beast and to solve the
problem the gang decides that the best
course of action is to dress trunks like
a girl and to offer him as a bride to
the monster it turns out that the Beast
cannot cause earthquakes but can only
sense when they are going to happen
which makes no sense considering the
perfect timing the earthquakes have in
the story shown up but let's ignore that
they beat him up they stop a volcano or
something and just as the Dragon Ball is
about to be handed over out of nowhere
some blue guy in a red unitard steals
the second dragon ball they spent two
agonizingly slow episodes retrieving I
feel cheated there is so much useless
Motion in this series but however I
spoke too soon what follows this is the
main plot of the Ark and it's probably
the worst anime anything I've ever seen
I'm going to try my best at describing
what happens and why I have a problem
with it I cannot promise I won't get
angry they begin chasing after the
unitards that stole the Dragon Ball
until they get lost in a big worm
Boulder
don't ask turns out a large group of bad
guys are looking for the Dragon Balls
Across the Universe without any means of
tracking them down no less first of all
how did they know that dragon balls were
out there now they only became viable
like last week additionally if they did
know about them why not go to where they
were created on Earth first before all
this happened also the odds of these
Yuri tired guys coincidentally running
into our gang as they found a dragon
ball with the help of a dragon radar is
astronomical the person that was looking
for the balls seems to be this Witch
Doctor that uses a whip to turn people
into dolls so that he can sacrifice them
to this creature called loot however was
the witch doctor receives the Dragon
Ball from the unitards he scolds them
for not getting the other Dragon Ball
that the gang had hold up how does this
guy know where the dragon balls are now
if he knows where they are then why were
the bad guys searching around the
universe for them blind
foreign
before we move on I'd like to take a
moment to touch on a wonderful little
short animation for genshin impact it's
only about two or so minutes long but
it's a stunning look at one of the
regions from the game and I think
regardless of how familiar you are with
the series itself it's a remarkably
touching piece it's always neat to see
International collaborations in
animation and that's the case here with
hoyo verse teaming up with French Studio
song Creature to produce this it's
packed to the brim with the most
stunning backgrounds that the camera
lingers over while understated animation
helps to bring things to life in a very
naturalistic way there's a real emphasis
on the fine detail of the world and it's
all placed against a delicate piano
piece that gives the animation a real
Serene feeling it evokes that same sense
of wonder you might get from watching a
Studio Ghibli movie more than anything
you just want to step inside the frame
and explore and I think that's pretty
genius as you do have the option to
Simply play the game if you want to take
a look yourself I've put a link in the
description for you I'm definitely
curious to see if they'll tell tackle
more regions in the future as I think
this type of material works great as not
only an advertisement but a legitimate
piece of art
it might sound like I'm skipping over a
ton of stuff here I'm sure a lot of you
are saying what no there must be more to
this than just that I'm sorry there's
really not I'm doing my best to glaze
over what isn't necessary and to focus
on the main plot points as they stagger
into my field of view here for instance
do you want me to go in depth with this
episode and explain how Beauty Tides go
back to the worm ball and control the
gang with dancing for literally minutes
and minutes of screen time
[Music]
no and neither do I because this is the
worst episode of Dragon Ball I've ever
seen the episode ends with pan getting
into trouble shocking accidentally
trying to fly the unitard spaceship to
lewd's Planet why because plot needs to
happen episode 11 long story short Pang
gets captured slash turned into a dollar
don't ask with a long story field finds
the guys and they come to rescue her a
giant robot line is introduced and in
seconds is destroyed by Goku where did
it come from doesn't matter the
explosion itself wipes out the witch
doctor guy holding the whip but wait the
whip is alive and turns into a golden
whip Warrior thing
episode 12 so we're introduced to the
real boss now I guess and it's this
weird alien guy with a soccer mom
haircut falling over doll pens so
delicately pretty convenient isn't it
how he decided to hang on to pan instead
of throwing her into the pot like he did
with the rest of the other worshipers
the weird alien with the soccer mom
haircut begins and dressing doll pan and
makes this face I think this is the
worst thing I've seen in a very long
time now if you were to ask me why is he
doing all of this why does he want to
resurrect loot I literally could not
tell you but lewd is finally activated
episode 13 a dumb looking pale green
alien robot baby reveals itself and it's
lewd in all of his glory why does it
have a flabby chest with nipples no idea
and it turns out the soccer mom haircut
wearing alien otaku guy isn't the real
boss either this guy Dr muis I gotta say
this now there have been like 30
different boss reveals first the person
that stole the ball then the leader of
his group then the witch doctor then the
whip then the whip turned into a golden
monster then the weird Dalo taku guy
with the sock mom haircut I know Dr Mew
this is incomprehensibly bad so it turns
out loot is being controlled by this Dr
Mew someone that looks like an
unlockable reskin of Dr gero from Dragon
Ball fighters in the end the unitards
come back and start dancing again
the fight between lewd and the team of
Goku and Trunks is boring and ultimately
Pan and the weird alien guy get absorbed
by Loot and believe it or not I actually
remember this part from when I was a kid
pan and Goku need to coordinate their
attack to the same area one shot from
the inside and one from the outside and
if my memory served me right it's pretty
dumb yep and it sure is the parapara
unitards who have all been absorbed by
elude 2 can conveniently communicate via
telepathy to Goku on the outside I hate
this show I I really hate this show can
I stop now eventually they hit lewd
right in the sweet spot at the exact
same time to defeat him while this was
happening lewd was just standing there
not defending himself waiting to be
attacked by Goku it's at this point in
the story I realize they've only
retrieved two dragon balls and I feel a
tremendous sadness descend upon me the
following two remaining episodes are
essentially filler or set up for the
later Antics in the next Arc episode 15
covers the guys landing on a desert
planet with pan getting into trouble
being saved by Gill which as it happens
is my favorite episode from this Arc
it's got nothing to do with the awful
main plot it's self-contained it sets up
the conflict between pan and Gail early
and despite pan treating Gil horribly he
still goes out to save her crazy to
think that the most resonant heroic
moment from the series so far for me has
been through a tiny plot device McGuffin
robot episode 16 on the other hand the
final episode in this hour covers the
gang landing on Gill's home planet as he
seemingly betrays them Goku and Trunks
get captured for a change and pan is
then left alone and that concludes the
Black Star Dragon Ball Saga what a mess
of the 16 episodes that made up the
story I could easily see it streamlined
down to 10 episodes if you remove the
episodes with unrelated material but
even saying that fact the main plot line
seemed to me at least confused and
ultimately it lacked Direction on June
of 2005 producer Kozo morishita had an
interview where he discussed the
production of Dragon Ball GT in an
effort to retain the golden time slot of
7 PM every Wednesday the brass behind
Dragon Ball decided to create a new
series in GT that would cover the
exploits of the Next Generation in pan
and Trunks this was part of the
reasoning for changing Goku to a kit to
keep him in theme with the younger
generation Dragon Ball GT itself wanted
to bring Dragon Ball back to its roots
with an adventure-centric storyline and
they definitely did that here however
Dragon Ball didn't just decide to go
from lighthearted adventure-centric
storytelling to galactic-wide battles
with world ending stakes in literally
one episode Dragon Ball gradually over
the course of a decade developed and
advanced the story to naturally assume
the stakes it did GT currently as it
stands already suffers from a lot of
issues and growing pains were not
something they needed on top of this
laundry list of defects and the
production issues and lack of confidence
in the product can be felt in this quote
taken straight from that interview
itself initially we made about 26
episodes worth of rough plot outlines
but around when the final script for
episode 3 was finished we thought these
travel episodes aren't going to be
interesting no matter how long we keep
them going are they and so we stopped
that's why Gill and the spaceship
stopped appearing midways through it's
clear from just watching it that it had
no idea of what it wanted to be one
second they're doing Wacky Adventures
throughout space for kids at another
second they're doing big battles
followed by more tone deaf slapstick
with creepy undertones it's all over the
place and I'm really not a fan of it the
entire story is filled with scenarios
where I can see the writer in various
circumstances writing themselves out of
a corner whether it be through pan
getting into specific kinds of trouble
to influence the main cast into
dangerous situations the bad guys
randomly deciding not to do away with
pan as a doll that catfish monster
having earthquakes with perf perfect
comedic timing or the uni Tides knowing
telepathy without which the situation
would be entirely lost Additionally the
writing is extremely formulaic and lazy
in that very same interview morishita
said Pan's rule was to be strong but
still lose to the enemies and then be
rescued by Goku a heroine who makes Goku
a hero Dragon Ball GT has an episode
where pan is turned into a doll but that
episode established the pattern of pan
sets the incident in motion while Goku
resolves it and that's Dragon Ball GT in
a nutshell extremely contrived formulaic
predictable and demonstrably
unforgivably relentlessly boring
foreign
last week our story Ended as gills
seemingly betrayed Goku Trunks and pan
by Leading them to his Homeworld where
he seems to be heralded as some sort of
hero as a key member among the ranks of
General rildo a subordinate of Dr mu it
has a nice change of pace Goku and
Trunks get kidnapped per Gill's
instructions leaving pan alone to figure
out some sort of plan to fix this
horrible situation honestly it's not a
terrible Cliffhanger and now that we're
all caught up let's go alrighty so this
entire 23.
long group of episodes I'll be watching
can be split into two separate stories
the first acting as a sort of setup to
the narrative that follows but that's
not to say that this first half can
stand on its own and isn't entertaining
in its own right that's right if you
thought I was here just a rag on GT then
I've got news for you I actually like
this part I am not going to nor have I
ever pretended to like or dislike
something simply because it's a popular
opinion I just share my own opinions as
I have them Win Lose or Draw but on this
occasion I actually really like this
part now that's not to say I think it's
perfect and I most definitely have my
issues with it but compared to the first
Arc it's like Ultra Instinct William
Shakespeare right off the bat the story
establishes who the point of view
character will be what the goal is and
what pan needs to do this is
advantageous because now that all of
that is understood by the viewer you're
now free to have fun finding wacky ways
for pan to infiltrate the compound that
holds her Grandpa in Trunks and those
Antics are very fun sneaking around
little bits of action here and there
with plenty of characters shining
through this is GT honestly at its best
for me and it was nice seeing pan in a
win for a change too she eventually
finds her way into the main chamber the
others are being held also finding
trouble for herself however in doing so
inspires Goku to free himself the next
episode doesn't really offer much it's
essentially a fighting heavy episode
following Goku as he dismantles the
forces of General rildo despite not much
happening narratively it's clear that
this episode and Arc is following a very
different story philosophy than the
original 16 that I reviewed in part 1.
the next episode is where things really
start to kick off however with some
beautiful artwork capturing Goku's first
altercation with General rildo and Pan's
attempt to reclaim trunks whom at this
time looks as though he's been frozen in
carbonite lots of Star Wars influence in
this Arc and now that I think about it
pan even got stuck in a trash compactor
in the earlier episode speaking of which
I should also mention while in that
trash compactor she met a friendly pink
alien robot this will be important later
the fight itself between General rildo
and Goku is actually quite good lots of
imaginative choreography and angles are
implemented things however at this time
don't look great for trunks who has been
just transported to Dr Muse laboratory
as the story continues Goku continues
his battle with General rildo eventually
gaining the upper hand before Ronaldo
reveals that he is the actual Planet
they are on very reminiscent of the
Dragon Ball Z movie The Return of Cooler
while this is all happening pan
continues in her attempts at
infiltrating the compound to rescue
trunks but without a means of
teleportation to Dr Mew pan is fighting
a losing battle however she manages to
run into her friend from the trash
compactor she helped Escape who offers
to help her in this endeavor with some
difficulty they managed to barge into
the complex but are quickly surrounded
once again however not one to go quietly
pan begins charging her Kamehameha
aiming it right at Gill and an army of
robots at the last second Guild
teleports are back to the front door
once again only this time with the
Dragon Balls we quickly switch back to
the fight between General rildo and Goku
as it rages on in various interesting
locations until pan rushes into the
battle showing Goku that she has the
Dragon Balls gorillo uses this
distraction as an opportunity to turn
both Pat and Goku into Carbonite
teleporting them both to Dr Mew also up
until now Gil has been helping the
forces of Dr Mew and General rildo in
their efforts to capture the Saiyans and
obtain the Dragon Balls however suddenly
Gill unfreezes Pat and Goku revealing
his traitor's actions in the past had
been a ruse in order to get the guys
closer to Dr mu trunks reveals himself
to be in perfect health and to have been
in on it the entire time orchestrating
this plan along with Gil in order to
tamper with and Destroy whatever Dr Mia
was working on I'm not sure if I'm a fan
personally of this swerve the story
intended to pull off while it was indeed
surprising it's not surprising because
it cleverly concealed the true nature of
trunks and Guild by means of
well-structured writing no it did so by
not giving any clues at all aside from
Gill giving Pan the Dragon Balls an
episode prior surprises like this work
best when it makes the audience say to
themselves oh of course it all makes
sense though even going back to the
first episode of this season this didn't
do that for me it's just a review feel
of another piece of information I
couldn't have predicted based on what
the story demonstrated so far to me that
said I don't dislike it really it's just
not what I was hoping for after this
Grand reveal trunks leads the gang into
this excessive unnecessarily massive
chamber housing an engineered parasite
known as baby while he floats there like
a good boy trunks reveals that he took
the initiative while everyone was
distracted to disarm the situation by
halting baby's development and Life by
way of computer virus this however does
not stop Dr Mew from going full psycho
trying to revive the artificial creation
while seeming futile his efforts do bear
fruit baby lives exploding forth from
his tank but is quickly taken out by
Goku pan and Trunks it looks over but
baby is not done as the gang tries to
escape the planet baby attempts to stop
them through General rildo's body the
episode ends with baby revealing that he
designed Dr Mew which to me honestly
sounds like it makes as much sense as
performing brain surgery on yourself
this isn't the last time we see baby
though following this there's a
collection of two episodes following the
gang as they stumble across a spaceship
wreckage holding within it a Dragon Ball
however after arriving gills senses a
life form on board an unconscious young
child they quickly transport the child
to a planet for Aid where it's revealed
that he and the rest of the ship he came
from had been eliminated by baby now
dwelling within the young child he
attempts to take over trunks's body but
ultimately fails in doing so because he
lacked the strength it's at this point I
thought the story was gonna go downhill
but it actually takes a major upswing we
hard cut to Earth and we are
reintroduced to Goten and his family I
love goten's new all about the ladies
and date character he still holds a
pleasant personality but with that Quirk
it adds some comedy and Edge to him that
I really enjoy while out on a date he
encounters a number of individuals who
have come under baby's influence he's
made it to Earth while the gang were out
Gathering the remaining Dragon Balls the
fight between queen baby and Goten is
honestly interesting with Goten
showcasing some of his fantastic new
personality however he ultimately Falls
as baby infiltrates his body at this
point baby's ultimate goal is to possess
Vegeta's body the strongest fighter on
Earth so he works his way up the pecking
order securing Gohan's body also in this
episode once baby takes a hold of Gohan
he makes a beeline for Vegeta who at
this time is on his way back from the
store with his daughter bra a wonderful
side effect of baby's character that
hasn't been seen before is that it
forces interesting matchups we wouldn't
expect to see normally an interesting
rematch too between Vegeta and Gohan who
haven't fought really since he was a kid
within this episode it's revealed that
baby can influence the minds of those he
was once within it's also explained that
he's a TOEFL creation and Vegeta
recognizes him the fight between the two
is honestly quite fun with nice
animation in places Additionally the
scene works very naturally for
exposition 2 which is always a plus baby
is an engineered TOEFL parasite with the
former TOEFL rulers DNA embed it within
it he can lay eggs in his former host to
maintain control over them and his goal
is to take revenge on the Saiyan race
that destroyed and stole his Homeworld
and to rule the universe because of
course it is while all this horribleness
is happening on Earth we switch back to
the gang in space as they finally
retrieved the last of the Dragon Balls
once they arrive back home it's revealed
to us but not Goku pan and Trunks that
the Earth has been totally overrun by
baby and his minions before the gang
goes their separate ways to their
respective homes they give the Dragon
Balls to a possessed dende and pan says
her goodbyes to Gill by tying her
bandana around the small robot while
this is all happening as a quick aside
Satan had the ingenious idea of hiding
inside Majin Buu I absolutely love that
Majin Buu is immune and it makes
complete sense very clever once Goku and
Pan arrive home they are ambushed by
babies minions but trunks's Ambush
specifically had much more of an
emotional weight behind it I think as
Vegeta lures trunks into the house
Gill's sensors are going off Dane danger
danger he says as Baby Vegeta Reveals
His True intent Guild beats him and
Trunks to the punch with some missiles
catching baby off guard protecting
trunks as baby begins talking trash
insulting and threatening the small
robot to stand down kill without
hesitation reloads his missiles compared
to pretty much everyone in this series
Gill is outmatched and he knows that
that's what makes this scene so powerful
for me and it actually got emotional
when baby took him out in the end and
it's not over that great scene is
immediately followed by the single best
reveal of the art and this Arc has a few
great reveals still to come baby it
turns out had control over trunks this
entire time he didn't activate him until
he brought the balls back which is
incredibly smart of him baby and an
exceptionally well delivered swerve by
the writers it makes complete sense from
both mechanical and motivational points
of view we then switch back to Goku's
situation as the fight rages on between
himself and Gohan went out of nowhere
Goten tries to Blindside him this
however is not a problem for Goku as he
blocks the blast with without even
looking Goku is much more serious in
this Arc which I'm honestly really happy
about Satan uses this lonely action to
fill Goku in on what's happened every
character is now up to speed and the
pieces are in place here's hoping they
can stick The Landing what follows is
Goku's first encounter with Baby Vegeta
and bad news he can't maintain Super
Saiyan 3 because of his infant body baby
on the other hand can absorb his
servant's power draining the energy from
Goten Gohan in trunks I sincerely
thought baby Vegeta's design looked much
more intimidating before this power
absorption however this is the start of
a trend unfortunately as baby gets
stronger his appearance goes from
looking like an intimidating infected
version of Vegeta to something that's
far less interesting in terms of design
and are overly complex and definitely
something that takes away from the
action for me with that said baby easily
defeats Goku meanwhile pan and Mr Satan
are safe for now thanks to Boo's Powers
baby then retires to his throne where he
uses the Dragon Balls to wish for his
home planet to be recreated this is
where some weird stuff starts to happen
but honestly I'm sort of into it Goku
finds himself sort of stuck in another
dimension I was worried it was a
complete deus ex machina but it turns
out that the Supreme kind made a save on
Goku at the last possible second before
he was defeated by baby it's actually
quite a clever idea using the Kai's
instantaneous movement during this Goku
ends up falling into another dimension
with his only means of Escape being a
decisive defeat of this character in a
dangerous board game it's silly but I
enjoy it for the same reasons I enjoy
snakeway's Antics Goku has difficulty
initial but finds out that that's
because the other guy is an absolute
cheat once this character's cheating is
exposed the game itself begins to fall
apart and Goku manages to escape the
dimension randomly appearing in a random
part of the universe once the Supreme
Kai senses his energy he plucks Goku and
the folks he rescued from the random
part of space back to safety I really
like this and to be honest I've really
enjoyed how the story has been
structured so far it's paste well baby
has an interesting power with a perfect
motivation the stakes feel massive and
most importantly they are doing a great
job at delivering surprises without
breaking the established rules and logic
of the Dragon Ball world it's honestly
very impressive after this Goku begins
his training on the world of the Kai's
while this is all happening pan her
Grandpa and boo devise a plan but in
order to enact this scheme that involves
laxatives they make their way to baby's
new planet in order to get close to him
and find more trouble than they
bargained for they are all attacked and
right as pan was about to be choked out
by her father Ube makes the save awesome
this Arc is so crazy oop fights baby but
quickly loses however during this boo
feels a connection to oop he brings
Satan and pan to safety and says his
goodbyes rushing in to make the save on
UB reuniting with him honestly a really
nice full circle moment for Majin Buu
and much better than what he got in
Dragon Ball super baby resumes his fight
against oot while this is happening the
kayots are in the middle of trying to
regrow Goku's tail the contrast of this
epic oob vs baby fight with Goku having
pliers on his butt is hilarious who
makes a misstep however turning himself
into chocolate instead of Baby Goku now
with his tail regrown rejoins the action
to fight baby he goes Super Saiyan 3
from the start but is quickly defeated
lying on a heap he begins staring at
Earth for calling his life there
suddenly Goku begins transforming into a
golden uzaru I have an issue with this
Earth acting as a substitute for the
Moon is weird and I really don't like it
naturally Goku has no control as the
uzaru but pan helps Goku regain control
by showing him a picture of when she was
little with him it's pretty touch it
immediately he begins transforming into
Super Saiyan 4. I don't think I need to
say this but it's an awesome design and
it's tailor-made for the baby saga
it's not looking good for the parasite
but in a matter of seconds a baby mind
control Bulma pulls a machine out of her
butt that harnesses the Earth's Bloods
waves and fires it at baby who has no
tail this is a real bad case of wanting
the fight to be a certain specific way
but not having the first clue of how to
get it there without breaking a number
of rules which is a shame because it was
so consistent before this baby begins to
transform into a golden goes arrow on
the bright side they have a built-in
excuse for baby to be able to control
this form Vegeta Knows how to and so
therefore baby can take advantage of
that there's also a nice shot where Goku
stands literally between the earth and
its destruction as baby fires a super
gallic gun Goku manages to block the
massive blast however baby has lost his
senses becoming what he hates the most
and out of control monster both baby and
Goku lie in Motionless completely Zapped
of their energy while this is all
happening the Kai's devise a plan to use
the Sacred Water from the garlic Jr Arc
of Z of all things to free those under
babies control it's a cute idea and I
actually kind of like it using this
water trunks is free from baby his
control and is tasked with finishing off
baby however Bulma still under baby's
control fires more [ __ ] I mean
Bloods waves at baby this for some
reason fully energizes him and Goku
staggers to his feet once again while
Goku is on the brink and with pan in
danger trunks sends a blast knocking
over baby Gohan Goten and the others
also come to Goku's rescue having been
freed from baby's control thanks to the
Sacred Water Goku requests that everyone
give him their power but baby doesn't
give him enough time suddenly something
begins happening to baby it's Ube and
he's alive inside of him apparently he
changed the chocolate on purpose to get
the jump on baby from the inside Goku
uses this time to absorb the other's
energy to replenish his own they
continue to fight with baby for an
episode and Goku blasts off his tail but
I thought he didn't need the tail with
the Bloods waves as Vegeta's body
reverts to normal size baby for some
reason remains gigantic within him
despite him being malleable for the
entire Arc this is honestly a terrible
way to keep Vegeta alive while removing
baby from his body also I guess baby
didn't lay eggs inside Vegeta either as
a last-ditch effort baby tries to escape
in a spaceship but Goku stops him by
blasting him into the sun they then
return the Earth to normal by spreading
the Sacred Water but since the dragon
balls were not brought back in time the
Earth explodes along with Piccolo who
decided to stay behind on Earth as it
exploded he did this in order to get rid
of the Dragon Balls Because he believes
that they cause more harm than good and
just like that Piccolo and the Earth are
gone the story ends as they use the
namekian Dragon Balls to restore the
Earth and everything back to normal
this was much much more enjoyable than
the first Arc in fact that's an
understatement from the very beginning
it was obvious that there was a much
clearer vision and goal for this story
and because it focused more in action
with sprinkles of Adventure it felt like
a much more natural continuation on from
Dragon Ball Z I also really like the
idea of baby being a parasite using his
foe to help him mature and take control
I also enjoyed his origin and motivation
watching him slowly slip and turn into
exactly what he hated most of all
foreign Invader mindlessly destroying
other planets and even his own in the
name of his race there were also plenty
of wonderful character moments too
through Gill pan Majin Buu and even
Goten I also really like that Super
Saiyan 4 allowed Goku to be an adult one
of my biggest gripes with Goku getting
turned into a kid was how his character
models stunted and negatively impacted
all the fights he took part in Akira
Toriyama changed Goku into an adult so
that he could make use of his longer
limbs as Dragon Ball focused more and
more on fighting Stumpy limbs don't
offer much in the way an interesting
posing despite making his kid self and
GT skinnier than the original appearance
was now that Super Saiyan 4 exists
within the story Goku can enjoy The Best
of Both Worlds doing all the
lighthearted stuff a kid would but when
he gets serious it's adult time and
finally the story managed to pull off
some wonderfully written surprises too
whether it being through trunks's body
being under the control of baby the
entire time boo housing pan and Mr Satan
safely or oob making the save on more
than one occasion with all of that said
I think this Arc still had some major
problems the swerve of trunks and Guild
being in cahoots at the beginning of the
arc doesn't really land like I would
have liked additionally General real
though isn't defeated he just sort of
becomes irrelevant also I didn't like
the Earth being used as a blotz wave
source and Bulma creating a blotwave
amplifier in minutes was utterly
ridiculous that was honestly probably
the arc's biggest blemish for me seeing
as the plot hinges on that mechanic for
baby and Super Saiyan 4. and finally the
fight should have ended one episode
sooner it should have ended right after
Ube revealed himself to be inside baby
that was a great swerve and the height
of the fight's action for me The
Following episode just shows more
useless one-sided fighting on the side
of Goku and honestly really ruins the
fight's memory and atmosphere in the end
however with that said despite these
drawbacks I think the baby Arc of Dragon
Ball GT was very very fun and in a lot
of places well thought out I can't wait
to see what the next Arc has in store
thank you
[Music]
episode 1 begins and they're the world
championship I'm excited I always love a
good dragon ball tournament but this is
actually filler and has nothing to do
with the story that follows so I'll
glaze over it as quickly as I can Goku
is fighting in the kids division because
Mr Satan is feeling depressed after what
happened to boo in The Last Arc and so
he wishes for pan to take his place by
winning the tournament but I spoke too
soon as Mr Satan is being given a
massage one of the tournament officials
explains that the four finalists have
been determined and pan has elected to
withdraw from the competition as she has
no interest in being the successor to Mr
Satan we switch over to Goku as the
Children's Division finals get underway
he's facing some unassuming kid called
Magyar magure I don't know however
before he gets a chance to begin Vegeta
barges in like a WWE wrestler demanding
a fight with Goku while Goku is
distracted mcgeor pushes Goku out and
wins thrilling stuff following that epic
display the adult divisions championship
match begins epicuri versus Iron Man the
fight begins and UB I mean papaya man
gives evichiri a German suplex after
which he immediately gives up papaya man
is the Victor and Goku tells him to
remove his mask it's oob because pan had
pulled out Mr Satan now has to face off
against oob who takes the fight pretty
seriously and starts thrashing on Mr
Satan right as he's about to deal the
finishing blow to Mr Satan boo stops oob
right in his tracks I kinda love that it
totally caught me off guard and UB
leaves himself wide open for Mr Satan to
land one punch knock him out of bounds
Satan gets emotional believing that he
won using his own abilities against oop
that's a really sweet Parting Gift Majin
Buu left for his grieving friend this
win gives Mr Satan new life and vigor
encouraging him to remain the world's
champion all in all this episode was
pretty cute nice self-contained story
that wraps everything up in a wholesome
bow at the end but now it's time for the
main entree episode 2. Dr Mew is still
alive I have several questions wait no
he finds himself walking aimlessly in
hell when he runs into Dr gero they
decide to join forces in their efforts
to bring an end to Son Goku I have no
idea how they're going to achieve this
from hell but I'm sure we're gonna find
out hard caught to Goku's house as his
friends and family are having a
get-together over dinner and knock on
the door reveals uninjured trunks on the
verge of collapse before fainting he
utters Android 17. investigating the
situation they notice a massive hole in
the clouds outside as they observe this
kinkai begins ringing in Goku's ear
informing him that for some reason the
living world and other world have become
stuck together we later learned that
this is due to an Android 17 and Hell
linking with Android 17 in the Living
World from the outset it looks as though
Android 17 in the living world is being
controlled in some capacity either by
the other Android or Giro in hell that
much is honestly still not understood
and I hope you don't miss King Kai
because that's literally the last time
we see him in this Arc once this is all
explain 17 challenges Goku to come to
hell alone because that would be the
smart thing to do in order to fight the
people he sent there now this Arc frames
it such that Goku is responsible for all
the villains being placed in hell what
follows is the release from hell and
pouring out onto Earth of all the
villains and news broadcast proceeds to
show images of escaping villains the
vast majority of which Vegeta ended the
lives of and not Goku and just as a
quick aside when it comes to even major
villains like Frieza and cell he might
have defeated Frieza but Future Trunks
sent him to Otherworld and cell was
defeated by Gohan regardless of all this
Goku accepts the challenge blindly
charging into the void alone and while
this is all happening the forces of
Earth defended from the villains that
have been released naturally when Goku
goes up to hell to confront 17 Dr gero
and Dr Mew they give him the slip and
proceed to Earth without him trapping
Goku in Hell who could have seen that
coming but that's not all the episode
comes to a close and it's revealed that
Frieza and cell remained in hell to face
off against Goku episode 3 kicks off as
Goku begins going to Toe with Frieza and
cell not being intimidated in the
slightest and exploding while powering
up it's not really a fight or even taken
seriously by Goku who literally surfs on
a kianzan thrown by Frieza needless to
say in a quick and embarrassing fashion
Goku begins dismantling the two Warriors
however one small hiccup they are
Immortal in hell i'll address that later
smash cut again to Earth as we see
Vegeta confronted by Napa this I thought
was a perfect time for some dialogue
between the two Saiyans giving Vegeta a
chance to express all the changes he has
undergone since their last parting but
nope he's gone in literally an instant
but fret not 17 is here to take his
place instead we then cut back to the
fight in hell as cell successfully
absorbs Goku but Goku somehow crawls
back out since that wasn't successful
Frieza and cell using a new technique
send him to Hell's basement or something
a place beneath the current hell they
dwell within underneath the clouds at
this point I honestly have no idea
what's going on Once In This Strange
Place Goku becomes part of a stew
prepared by this old woman but that's
not all unfortunately in this strange
place she places Goku in a number of
strange and uncomfortable scenarios I
don't know what her goal is here exactly
and her preventing him from moving I
don't even know is necessary can Goku
even get out of here is
it I have honestly no idea because
tension that I only are trying to
achieve doesn't exist or have the chance
to exist as I have no idea what the
parameters of this realm even are what's
possible here we cut to Earth as Android
17 encounters Android 18 managing to put
her under some sort of mind control my
assumption is the same mind control at
17 is currently under himself the fourth
episode kicks off in a major way Krillin
attempts to reach 18 and 17 as all of
this is going on expressing his
confusion as to why 17 is working for
Giro thinking that he once resented him
why is he working for him he expresses
it seems to work for a moment but
quickly 17 snaps back under this evil
influence firing a blast straight
through Krillin leaving his body
lifeless in the arms of his wife Android
18. and man does she lose it absolutely
savaging and brutalizing her brother for
what he's done screaming to give Krillin
back it's honestly really powerful raw
stuff and one of if not the most
powerful scenes I've ever seen from
Android 18 since her introduction to the
show 17 however is much more powerful
than her unfortunately easily leaving
her in a heap next to her husband before
making his way to his doppelganger back
in Hell Frieza and cell discover Goku
after being frozen in ice by the old
woman taking advantage of this they
charged their final blast to destroy the
Saiyan however in the nick of time Goku
manages to break free from the ice the
ice can only keep those who are already
dead Frozen apparently and so he turns
the tables on them using that very same
ice trap we switch back to Earth as the
Android 17 from hell is evenly matched
against Vegeta who for some reason
doesn't go Super Saiyan but not for long
the other 17 arrives and quickly begins
to change things they fuse I don't like
this idea personally this story didn't
really convince or sell me on this
concept successfully and I'm really not
a fan of the design personally but let's
see how things pan out they all begin
rushing Super Android 17 because that's
the smart thing to do in this situation
resulting in pretty much how you imagine
it going down everyone getting debt and
while this is all happening Goku is
trying to figure out a way to get out of
hell apparently Emma can't do it as
something outside of his control or our
knowledge is preventing him as this is
said it shows the Dragon Balls cracking
I have no idea what this means yet
Piccolo during this interrupts this line
of thought
somehow requesting to be placed in hell
so yema can put Piccolo in hell but not
take Goku out
it seems convenient anyways Piccolo has
a plan episode 5. okay so Piccolo's plan
is to connect the Earth with other world
the same way the 217s did at the
beginning using his connection with Den
day okay first of all he can communicate
with dende beyond the grave okay fine I
mean I thought you needed someone like
King Kai to do that but whatever what I
want to know is why did Piccolo need to
be brought to hell in the first place
couldn't he have communicated this to
Goku and told him to make a connection
with him in one of his sons earlier
surely they are more similar than
Piccolo and then they are and Piccolo
ends up not even being able to do it
until Goku helps him anyway whatever
once the Gateway is open Goku uses this
as an opportunity to leave and join the
battle on Earth against Super Android
17. however before he arrives Vegeta is
on the verge of being sent to Otherworld
himself that is until pan takes things
into her own hands holding Dr gero
hostage with guilt the real MVP she
demands that Super Android 17 stop in
his tracks and he does he stops aiming
at Vegeta and switches to stuff in Jero
and pan this swerve is insanely bad Dr
Mew begins laughing facing the other
doctor practically twirling his mustache
explaining that while they were
developing the Android another world
off-screen might I add he enhanced him
such that he would only listen to his
commands and needless to say this
results in gero's demise Vegeta quickly
regains his footing and begins
blustering about how he doesn't need
Kakarot how he's the real number one Etc
only two seconds later be saved by
Kakarot bringing the episode to a close
we are now entering the final two
episodes and so Begins the battle
between Super Android 17 and Goku Goku
punches the Android once and sends him
literally to the other side of the
planet Android 17 proceeds to express
how Goku is letting him down very cliche
at this point I'm just waiting for Super
Saiyan 4. yet Goku persists in only
using the regular Super Saiyan form also
as another quick aside the sheer number
of times Android 17 in this Arc has
pushed back his hair in the exact same
way is more than the number of scenes
Piccolo has had in this entire Series so
far just saying anyways Goku gets right
up into his face and fires a point blank
Kamehameha 2-0 effect and so finally
Super Saiyan 4 comes out and we can
start taking things seriously we then
smash cut to possibly the last thing I
expected a short scene with Chichi Bulma
Videl and pra as they make plans to join
the action too I have no idea what's
happening anymore anyways
Droid is absorbing Goku's blast and so
naturally because this is how the fight
is written Goku begins firing an
enormous and unreal
random key blasts that are completely
out of character for him also Super
Android 17 has this ability to absorb
energy despite both Android 17
specifically not having that ability at
all and even if I were to ignore that
the fight is so boring because the
Android can absorb his key attacks when
Goku learns this he acts as if his hands
are tight Goku is not just a key attack
guy the entire fight with Frieza on
Namek while it did have key attacks
Incorporated the vast majority was
martial arts hand-to-hand Close Quarters
combat and another thing to confirm that
the Android was absorbing the attacks
Goku fires his strongest blast at him so
one of two things would happen in this
instance either his assumption that he
does in fact absorb his energy would be
proven correct and he does absorb that
energy or he'd blow up the Earth because
he's aiming downwards episode 7. the
final episode kicks things off as the
girls are making their way to the action
for some reason Goku manages to dodge
the Android's big attack and teleports
behind him using all of his limbs to
restrain him in this moment Goku begins
to gather power and releases a giant
burst of energy as the dust clears Goku
is in his infant base form once again
and the Android is still alive
apparently he raised his barrier or
something Super Android 17 begins
charging the same blast he did earlier
to finish off Goku when out of nowhere
Android 18 appears on the battlefield
she begins reprimanding him for sending
Krillin to other world and Goku hears
this news she apparently survived the
last attack at the hands of her brother
because he was purposely avoiding her
vital area that once housed a bomb
placed there by the late Dr Giro however
it has unbeknownst to Android 17 been
removed by the dragon and so Android 18
begins to Bluff while this is all going
on Dr Mew begins calling 17 pathetic and
a coward for not firing on Goku and 18
anyway resulting in you guessed it Dr mu
being blown up instead at the hands of
17. 18 uses this moment of distraction
as an opportunity to unload a
bombardment of key attacks on the Super
Android resulting in him absorbing all
of the energy she releases Goku notices
that when he absorbs the energy he needs
to have his body in a particular pose
what a strange design choice leaving
himself wide open for attack and Goku
does just that flying right through him
with a dragon fist and Landing
consecutive kamehameha's finishing the
fight not a fad the episode wraps up as
they conclude that 17 must have known
about the bomb and still missed
intentionally because she was his sister
the girls arrived but are too late and
they take care of any and all Loose Ends
With the Dragon Balls oh boy where do I
begin okay Dragon Ball GT's first Arc
was Mindless Adventure baby's Ark was
fighting mixed with Adventure each facet
fighting and Adventure serving a purpose
in telling the story of the baby Ark in
this Super Android 17 Arc it's the
opposite of the first instead of
mindless Adventure it's just Mindless
fighting the ark is almost exclusively
fighting and the fights have no weight
behind them all of these villains have
been defeated get no dialogue and are
simply there to facilitate numbers to
prevent and give trouble to Earth's
forces which we barely see additionally
where the Last Arc with baby succeeded
The Arc being just about him this Arc is
not really about Android 17 consistently
shifting Focus from him to various other
villains that ultimately have little or
nothing to do with the main story and
its climax in other words it doesn't
build up to anything at its core this is
a Revenge story sort of the two doctors
getting their revenge on Goku yet the
two doctors are eliminated by 17 who has
no known motivation to us in the story
what does he want if he wants what Dr
Mew wants then why did he remove him
entirely I really didn't like this
aspect of the story and it only further
emphasized that the people in charge of
this only wanted to create excuses for
them to fight and had nothing to say
well little to nothing to say the scenes
including Android 18 and Krillin were
honestly very touching and hit all the
right notes for me personally The Arc
was at its best when she and her husband
were on screen amazing I think how they
played such a small role while being so
important to the story it's a bit of a
waste in all honesty speaking of waste
the stuff that happens to Goku and hell
isn't compelling it's all rather silly
and takes up too much time within this
already very short story it keeps
introducing new aspects of the hell
landscape that weren't privy to us prior
therefore they don't act as surprises
just conveniences to keep Goku locked
down in there like yema not being able
to pull him out of there or there being
a basement to hell at all or Goku being
able to melt just because he's alive
stuff like that and all of these new
reveals don't really add anything to the
story they just facilitate ways to delay
it for Goku to proceed and for sell and
Frieza to finally meet their defeat in
Hell speaking of Frieza and cell why is
it that they are Immortal in hell this
makes no sense to me during the end of
Dragon Ball Z in the final fight against
Kid Buu wasn't it stated to Vegeta that
if he loses here while in the afterlife
he won't be able to come back that he'll
stop existing or something Additionally
the entire Arc hinges on this
brainwashing of the Android's angle and
yet it's never explained how this is
even possible or even how Dr gero and Dr
Mew found the supplies or parts
necessary to create Android 17 in hell
it's just glazed over as if it's some
unimportant detail yet the entire story
is built upon it my final criticism for
this Arc is that the fights were
honestly really boring perhaps this was
because they had no emotional weight for
me but I genuinely wasn't impressed by
the action even on a surface level
everything looks standard and Blair and
those are my thoughts on Dragon Ball
GT's Super Android 17 Saga Blair a saga
that felt about as good as a rush book
report and felt slower and more
monotonous than the vast majority of
sagas despite it only really being six
episodes long if you don't include the
filler episode at the beginning
currently GT is batting one for three so
far so not exactly a fantastic record
okay so to provide some catch up and
context in the last episode Goku managed
to defeat Super Android 17 and in an
attempt to return the Earth back to
normal gather the Dragon Balls to make a
wish however something isn't quite right
all the way through the Last Arc or so
the Dragon Balls have been seen with
cracks appearing and chippings covering
their once Flawless exterior and when
finally gathered during the final
episode of The Last Arc something
unusual begins to emerge from the boss
some evil key and a Sinister looking
Dragon again not a bad setup at all the
premise is interesting and it links the
prior Arc with this one very very well
bringing us to episode one The episode
opens and Shenron is looking a little
worse for wear he announces that he
won't be the lap dog to anyone anymore
and King Kai begins explaining that the
Dragon Balls have become tainted by
negative energy from overuse at this
point I'm sure kenkai is only being used
for exposition and literally nothing
more Shenron then absorbs the dragon
balls and flies off in different
directions as seven separate dragons
because because the Dragon Balls have
been overused those monsters were born
and released from within them by
developing the dragon radar and using
the balls flippantly over the last 30
years they have abused their powers and
created disorder within nature now the
earth and the universe are in Peril and
that's pretty much the gist of things
this story is going for Goku assumes
responsibility and Journeys to fix the
issue in his commute to doing so
disasters begin occurring all over the
world volcanoes Avalanches lightning
storms Twisters cities being destroyed
that sort of thing each disaster having
its own dragon behind it and as Goku is
searching for the dragons he realizes
that he has no idea where he's going and
that's when pan appears from behind him
with Gill a functional Dragon radar
although I am less than happy with the
tenuous reason pan is being allowed to
tag along together they happen Upon A
small area covered in what looks like
sludge Gil begins alerting them that a
dragon is nearby and that's when they
have their very first encounter the
setup for this has honestly been great
with plenty of tension building up to
this reveal and episode 2. so it turns
out that this dragon is super super weak
and pan begins to take this as an
opportunity to show Goku what she's
really made of dismantling the toad
light dragon with relative ease this
Dragon totally took the wind out of my
sails and the tension out of this entire
Arc for me and here's a small spoiler it
doesn't get much better than this for a
while this to me at least wasn't the
dragon to start off this search with but
whatever as the Fight Continues he gains
more and more strength eventually
overpowering pad it turns out that
there's something up with this Dragon
apparently he emits negative energy
causing whomever is nearby to have its
energy sucked from it and so while he
isn't getting any stronger pan and Goku
are most certainly getting weaker and
weaker the more they hang around him
additionally according to this Dragon he
was born from a specific wish made to
return oopa's father to life meaning
each Dragon was created by a specific
wish from the past which is honestly a
really nice touch I think once he
finishes explaining this the two of them
are drained of energy and he hits them
with a blast and dumps them into a
poisonous Lake and right at the last
second Guild comes out of no where to
make the save what a legend but the
attack was ineffective leading Guild to
get smacked into the water before pan
and Goku are thrown in but once again
gills saved the day dragging both pan
and Goku into an unpolluted part of the
lake using this moment of respite a
fully charged Goku and Pan take out the
dragon retrieving a fully restored
orange Dragon Ball episode 3 Goku and
Pat are in search of another Dragon Ball
when they arrive in this town eventually
coming across some sort of slime which
apparently has sucked up all the
electricity this is driven out the
townsfolk and that's the premise of this
episode a small Dragon then reveals
himself to be the culprit and covers the
two Saiyans in this electric slime to
the dragon surprise Goku and Pan get up
relatively unharmed in response to this
he begins Gathering all of his slime
growing in size in response to that Goku
goes Super Saiyan 4 but still fails to
stop him the electric slime Dragon Gets
yet stronger Again by sucking the energy
from the power lines growing bigger and
taking a hold of Goku and Pan he
literally defeats both of them and right
as he's about to deal the decisive Blow
by pure chance it's it starts to rain
resulting in him sort of
short-circuiting and eventually losing
his life what an awful fight what an
awful ending but at least they got the
five-star ball and more importantly this
episode is over next in this episode we
deal with yet another Dragon while
closing in on another ball the gang
stumbles upon a village as it starts
raining fish the town worships this
princess figure as she delivers fish to
them or something some kid has a bad
relationship with his father and it's
very sad and totally worth focusing on
because I care deeply about it where the
hell is the plot oh here it is Gil
begins detecting the Dragon Ball coming
towards them from across the bay it is a
girl and I guess that explains the whole
princess thing apparently this Dragon
was created using the panties wish in
the very first Arc of Dragon Ball much
to her embarrassment and so she attacks
for whatever reason none of their
attacks seem to touch her however it
turns out that that is just a barrier
she puts up as she is in fact a monster
with a grotesque outer exterior Goku
begins spinning around turning into the
genie from Aladdin I wish I was joking
and starts to back and once again
finding great success but this is
short-lived and soon after is sent
flying into a wall but thanks to a
seagull guess I'm serious Goku and Pen
find the opening they needed to wrap up
this episode's Dragon Ball thanks I hate
it next in this episode they face off
against a ground Dragon one that digs in
case that wasn't clear okay so this was
getting to be a tired formula two
episodes ago but now it's honestly
putting me to sleep the dragon they're
pursuing doesn't even want to fight so
they spend the entire first half of this
episode just chasing him however it
becomes clear that they need to stop him
when he reaches a nearby Town Goku goes
Super Saiyan 4 to save some civilians
and because Goku stopped the
earthquake's destruction which the mole
Dragon caused they begin fighting
apparently he was born from the wish
made at the World Martial Art tournament
rectifying what Vegeta did the fight
finishes like you all know it will Goku
fights with it for a while it makes a
mistake and then loses one thing that's
different this time however is that the
Dragon Ball starts to absorb pen so
that's interesting the dragon re-emerges
looking more intimidating having
absorbed the young Saiyan episode
episode 6. so apparently he had been
using this mole as a host before and now
he would be using pan as the host
resulting in a more powerful Dragon I
guess Goku right now needs to defeat him
without destroying pan in the process
which honestly complicates things at the
very least the dragon knows that Goku
won't fight back to prevent pan and so
he begins destroying the city Goku tries
to put up a strong front turning super
saiyan knocking him around however he
soon catches on that Goku has been
holding back intentionally the dragon
begins calling Goku's Bluff and as he
continues destroying the city pan from
within the Beast begs Goku to take him
and her out together and eventually he
does with a 10 times Kamehameha but not
really apparently Goku's heart wasn't in
it and so the blast failed to take out
the monster how strong are these guys
whatever in a moment of ego and
Cockiness the dragon shows pan one last
time to Goku who seizes the moment by
yanking her right out once pan is freed
Goku goes 100 and destroys the dragon
with relative ease retrieving the Dragon
Ball bringing the episode finally to a
close episode 7 almost all of these
episodes begin the exact same way with
Gill doing his job alerting the two of
them to dragon balls that are nearby and
pan getting annoyed either shouting at
him or attacking him for some unknown
reason not only is this boring seeing
the same joke land again and again and
again but it also doesn't endear me to
Pan's character who I really want to
like but back to the episode the city
that they've arrived in is super hot so
I'm guessing that's this one's theme and
yep it sure is the four star dragon
reveals himself and it's the first
design that looks like it was taken
somewhat seriously upon seeing the
dragon pan makes a Mad Dash to take him
out and with ease the dragon knocks her
out but doesn't do anything further he
wants to have a regular battle with Goku
uninterrupted as they fight he reveals
that he can momentarily raise his body
temperature to the level of the sun
which is quite hot I'm told but so much
of this early fight is spent with Goku
running away from this guy which seems
really out of character for him I mean
yeah he's hot but throw some key blasts
at him or something maybe go out of base
form you have Goku and eventually he
does making the last 10 minutes feel
like otter filler we then cut to Gill as
he's tending to pan when out of nowhere
he's knocked to the side by some ice
dragon finally the plot is changing
things up which my sanity is grateful
for he looks the exact same as the four
star dragon but blue the fight that
transpires between the Four Star Dragon
and Goku is honestly pretty creative
utilizing their environment to change
things up the dragon fires his attack
through a lens to magnify its intensity
and Goku has the great idea to use the
taio-ken or solar flare through that
very lens knocking him for a loop both
Fighters get up and now it's time to
take things seriously the dragon sheds
his skin to reveal a hotter exterior and
Goku goes Super Saiyan 4 to end the
episode episode 8. you'd think this
episode would cover Super Saiyan 4's
battle against the four-star Dragon but
it doesn't we cut instead to Vegeta who
wants to help but feels like he can't
without the power of Super Saiyan 4 and
thus begins an entire episode flashing
back through Vegeta's story essentially
the plot of this episode is that Bulma
has found a way to make Vegeta a Super
Saiyan 4 using a machine which on one
hand given Vegeta's story is a nice
change of pace for him consistently
Vegeta's fought against allowing himself
to be loved and to love other people
focusing instead on his own strength and
building that up however now those loved
ones can help him become stronger than
he ever could alone that is a nice thing
and I appreciate that but a machine
granting him that ability feels very at
odds with what dragon Ball's philosophy
is and doesn't feel earned to me now
don't get me wrong I'm not against
helping him at all I mean the gravity
chamber was a nice way for Bulma to help
Vegeta to help himself but this one just
sort of feels like a free pass as
episode 9 then kicks off so too does the
fight between Goku and the dragon who
seems to have Goku beat in the speed
department but through the bizarre use
of a mirror Goku gets to jump on him
however he gives him a second chance
because he let pan go the fight
therefore is reset when suddenly out of
nowhere the ice dragon freezes Goku's
arm he begins berating his brother for
being so foolish in battle and as Goku
dashes to Pan's side the ice dragon
freezes limb after limb of Goku until he
can't move the ice dragon then orders
his brother to finish him off but he
ultimately refuses and unfreezes Goku
who now has his eyes set on taking out
the cold Dragon episode 10 in powering
off the ice dragon freezes the entire
city to prevent Goku from taking him out
he uses pan as a hostage throwing the
child at Goku who catches his
granddaughter using his back to block
the oncoming attack that's a nice bit of
choreography I think and actually works
from a storytelling perspective too but
Goku gets the upper hand eventually
outclassing the cold-hearted ice dragon
getting him down to his knees begging
for his life he offers the ball to Goku
in exchange before trying to catch Goku
once again off guard in falling for this
underhanded trick Goku's eyes take the
brunt of the damage resulting in him
being blinded moving in for the final
blow the ice dragon dashes only to be
met with a fist through the chest by
Goku who reveals that he does not need
to see to win and when he most certainly
does receiving the three-star ball while
still unable to see you Goku is handed a
cure by the fire dragon whom he is now
befriended as the two are about to go
their separate ways the four-star dragon
is shot down by a blast revealing the
final one star dragon the main bad guy
of this Arc in an effort to protect Goku
once again the four-star Dragon
sacrifices himself there's one Dragon
left and it's the most powerful one and
they begin to fight but remember Goku is
still blind here he never managed to use
the potion the other Dragon gave him and
that potion has been destroyed since
then the fight is honestly quite
entertaining with a lot of creative
action set pieces being implemented at a
fair within the chaos of the battle Goku
manages to land his strongest move on
the one star dragon 2-0 effect reacting
to this the dragon fires back with an
attack of his own leaving Goku hanging
lifeless from a building scaffold
episode 11 as he hangs from the building
Goku reverts back to his child form
defeated as the one star dragon drops go
from the building lifelessly to meet his
Doom out of nowhere Goten arrives to
make the save with Ube Gohan and trunks
everyone's there to support Goku
including Videl Chichi and even Mr Satan
the group begins instilling their power
into Goku but they are interrupted by
the one star dragon that has now been
called Shenron the dragon targets Gohan
first and then eyes off the rest of them
who all get saved by Goku at the last
second using Instant Transmission
despite it being a technique he can't
use effectively as a kid convenient but
I digress who manages to distract them
long enough for Goku to absorb his
friends and Family's Powers resulting in
his superpowered Super Saiyan 4. at this
point Goku can't be touched by Shenron
despite being blind after some action
that includes throwing a clock around
Goku lands at 10 times Kamehameha on
Shenron and all is right with the world
again it seems but Shenron has survived
and begins absorbing the Dragon Balls
one by one gaining all of their powers
episode 12. at this point I want to make
known that I hate this Shenron design
with a burning passion the battle rages
on back and forth Shenron demonstrating
that he can use the other dragon's
techniques at this point our hero Goku
is pretty low but he somehow threw the
power of plot gets his eyesight back and
lands a massive attack on Shenron
seemingly defeating him but again the
dragon recovers using once again another
one of the dragon's special techniques
healing his own body despite me being
pretty certain that's not how that
particular dragon's ability works also I
have no idea why he isn't using the
first dragon's technique you know the
one that sucked the energy out of
everything I mean he'd be winning now if
he was but whatever some more back and
forth continues and Goku finally gets
him restrained looking to take him out
the same way Vegeta did with boo but out
of nowhere Vegeta interrupts this and
using bulma's machine begins
transforming into an uzaru and
eventually Super Saiyan 4. but what
really impresses me about this scene is
exactly something I actually criticized
in Dragon Ball super in Dragon Ball GT
Vegeta not Goku Vegeta is the one that
brings forth the idea of fusion and that
shows a ton of character growth episode
13 the two Saiyans views creating Super
Saiyan 4 Gogeta and Shenron cannot touch
them and Gogeta is toying with him in
really unamusing ways if I'm being
perfectly honest it gets very old very
fast and really sucks the tension out of
what was an episode that already lacked
a lot of tension for me Shenron gathers
all the energy he can muster into one
blast and Gogeta just kicks it away
easily and that's when out of nowhere
suddenly the world becomes normal again
apparently when Gogeta kicked the ball
he converted the energy from negative to
positive which okay Gogeta then hits him
with a big bang Kamehameha releasing all
of the dragon balls but for some reason
this guy still refuses to kick the
bucket and wouldn't you know it the
fusion ends despite it being only 10
minutes and the fusion expires because
of power or something where have I seen
that before episode 14. okay okay so
Shenron won't let them fuse again and
Goku eats the four star bald because
obviously for a little while there's a
bit of a cat and mouse game going on
here Goku and Vegeta want to fuse but
Shenron isn't giving them the chance to
why doesn't Goku just teleport somewhere
safe with Vegeta to do it there
I don't know anyway after 20 minutes of
being thrown through buildings they
decide to use their after image
technique and once again become Goji but
no it didn't work because Goku was low
of energy they tried once again leading
to Goku reverting back to base form he
is completely Zapped of energy episode
15. now with Goku as a kid and Vegeta in
Super Saiyan 4 they need to figure out
how to salvage this situation and that's
when they known as Goku has the four
star ball on his forehead the four star
dragon then comes out of the ball and
hits an oncoming Blast away the four
star dragon claims to have been infected
by Shenron when he absorbed him earlier
and now fights Vegeta whom he easily
overpowers and is now down for the count
and after knocking Goku to the curb it
seems chances are Grim but when Vegeta
Rises to his feet he comments that the
four-star Dragon had been pulling his
punches that's when we noticed that
shenron's guard is now down leaving the
perfect opportunity for the 4 star
dragon to dash in behind him and
restrain him the four star dragon begins
to Glow lock him inside some sort of
heat ball oh I don't know what would you
call it Fireball yeah that's probably
better he self-destructs this fire Heat
ball exploding the two of them scarring
the landscape beneath the four-star
Dragon lands to the floor seemingly
Victorious and that's when Shenron
emerges from his carcass like a spiky
butterfly from a chrysalis I have okay I
caught for a second I have no idea
what's happening this show is Bonkers so
Shenron put himself inside the body of
the soup of the four-star dragon and
then he burst out again but he also
exploded
and that's when Vegeta drops back to
base form too because enough bad things
haven't happened already yet I guess he
turns to Bulma who points out that the
machine is being destroyed and therefore
can't produce any more Bloods waves to
you know power him up again but little
does she know that she can pull another
one out of her butt super easy because
she did that during the baby Saga
episode 16. there's really no tension
for me at this point Goku and Vegeta
struggle against Shenron who has now
sidelined Vegeta and sent a blast
towards the Earth Goku now stands
holding back the blast in his Base Kit
form reaffirming to me that I have no
idea how strong anyone in this show
actually is Goku manages to somehow
deflect the blast and at this point I
can't help but fret the characters like
Goten Trunks and pan have little to
nothing to contribute to this final
fight barely getting any shine in the
story at all never mind from a dialogue
perspective Vegeta goes on to lament
over his Planet being destroyed by
Frieza and now this planet is about to
follow the same path ordering everyone
to hop onto a spaceship with Bulma to
survive that that is the main priority
it's a pretty strong moment for Vegeta
charging headfirst into battle while
ordering his children and Goku's
children to someday avenge them it's a
really cool scenario and to be perfectly
honest it would have been a pretty cool
premise for a story too but perhaps a
little too dark for Dragon Ball while
Vegeta holds him off Trunks and the rest
of the kids decide to help anyway which
is a dumb decision and makes all of
their lives useless now together they
attack to no effect and that's when Goku
rises from the rubble with a Spirit Bomb
the first one of the series 2 and this
is a pretty cool visual possibly my
favorite looking Spirit Bomb in the
entire series not just GT so how about
that Goku uses King Kai to communicate
to the universe and gathers energy from
throughout he throws the bomb and the
fight is over Goku lies lifeless on the
floor and the Dragon Balls released the
original Green Dragon Shenron by
themselves ending the episode which
brings us to Dragon Ball GT's final ever
episode and man it's a doozy but like
the other episodes let's go through it
slowly to figure out how it works the
episode opens as Shenron unprovoked
heals Goku of his injuries and awakens
him Shenron begins explaining that due
to their over-reliance on the balls the
earth and the Integrity of the Dragon
Balls themselves have been compromised
on more than one occasion and so
announces that he will be leaving Goku
quickly interjects and requests that the
earthlings that have fallen be brought
back to life not that the Earth itself
be fully restored to the way it was just
to bring back the earthlings to life
explaining that they can all work
together to restore the Earth themselves
which honestly for me was a really nice
touch Shenron agrees and the earthlings
are brought back the group share a smile
and celebrate the successful wish but
that is almost immediately brought to an
abrupt stop as Shenron asked Goku to
come along with him Goku seems to know
where he's going and says that he'll see
everyone later and as Goku flies off on
the back of Shenron he asks if he can
stop at a few places before they leave
for good the first stop is Master
Roshi's home where he is reacquainted
with the hermit turtle and his longtime
pal Krillin they shoot the breeze and
reminisce over their old train days when
Krillin says this
[Music]
Goku can see the hurt and Krillin when
he says this and with an unblinking
smile he asks if Krillin would like to
Spire for old time's sake allowing
Krillin to land one last punch building
up his confidence before leaving for
good a nice pounding gift to his
one-time rival and long time best friend
the next and final stop Goku wanted to
make was to see Piccolo whom at this
time is residing in hell it seems he's
content working as effectively their
security guard while there which
honestly is nice Goku appears before him
requesting to shake his hand saying
these parting words
foreign
Piccolo confused and distressed over
what's been said turns to find that Goku
is once again gone at this point the
episode switches back to the gang and
Earth following Goku's departure they
all begin going their separate ways but
trunks notices that pan is still staring
up at where Goku left trunks reassures
her that the Dragon Balls would one day
return and that they need to First help
ensure that their strength is enough to
protect the earth and the Universe on
its own as they leave pan notices Goku's
clothes on the floor picking them up
Vegeta from outside of her point of view
tells her to hold on to that last piece
of Goku dearly as if to suggest that
Goku was a very important person worthy
of fondly remembering even for Vegeta
with that Goku falls asleep on the back
of Shenron as the Dragon Balls disappear
into the tired Saiyan's body the scene
Fades to black as we cut to the next
scene the World Martial Arts
championships Junior finals match in the
distant future a new spiffy young
announcer begins introducing a fighter
by the name of Sun Goku it's revealed
that this young boy is a distant
descendant of the Son Goku we're all
familiar with who along with Mr Staton
now as a statue commemorating him at the
World Martial Arts Tournament grows pan
is seemingly at this point the last
remaining character we all know Alive
Now a doting grandmother of the young
Son Goku looking out from the sidelines
as her grandson takes the stage wearing
the same tattered clothes her Grandpa
Left Behind many many years ago as a
cute turn of events Goku Jr's opponent
happens to be an ancestor of Vegeta
bearing a striking resemblance the two
begin clashing in dramatic fashion
assuming even Super Saiyan when pan
notices something in the corner of her
eye
[Applause]
what follows this is honestly an
intensely nostalgic look back at the
journey we have all shared with Goku
through the series as he walks under the
Martial Arts Tournament grounds the
final lines of the story being goofy
cheerful and gentle that's the Sun Goku
we all loved this is where the story of
Dragon Ball ends what an outrageously
appropriate touching and utterly
beautiful way to close the book on what
is to millions and millions of young
people and old throughout the world
their childhood their inspiration and
even at times their friend and if this
Arc was simply just this episode I'd
have nothing but fantastic things to say
but let's talk about this Arc as a whole
before I end on a positive note I really
wanted to make this Arc two separate
videos as talking about the ending and
the arc to me at least feel like two
separate talking points so let's take
one before the other in this video The
Arc as a whole had what is to me and
probably to most people who took the
time to watch it a very interesting and
fitting premise for a story within the
Dragon Ball Mythos there is absolutely
an over-reliance on the dragon balls and
to convince your audience that there are
consequences for that over-reliance
isn't a tough sell but the execution of
it felt incredibly formulaic at the best
of times and Incredibly boring at others
for me a worry that I had from the start
was that with the premise as it was an
evil dragon emerging forth from each
individual Dragon Ball I feared that it
would just turn into a monster of the
weak type format and it pretty much did
at least for a while five episodes
covered the exact same formula show up
in a town fuel alerts them to a nearby
Dragon Ball pan hit skills for no reason
they find the dragon that's causing
trouble to the city Village or town and
they defeat it and then the town is
better five episodes in a row follow
this very predictable boring tired
format and it really hurt the show for
me additionally with a premise and
villains as easily justifiable as these
the dragons are given no motivation at
all they are just evil because they have
no reason to be evil they just are I
don't really like that they don't have
an underlying motivation at all they
refer to themselves as evil which to me
just isn't interesting the final villain
for this story really felt lifeless for
me like he had no personality and was a
cookie cutter by the books Dragon Ball
villain simply there to facilitate big
moments for the heroes to rise to unlike
characters like Vegeta and Frieza who
improved the battles simply by being who
they were additionally his design really
didn't do anything for me I know this is
a subjective thing but it really just
felt more Digimon than Dragon Ball if
that makes sense and finally pan I
admire Dragon Ball GT for wanting to and
in many cases successfully achieving a
believable and interesting new character
in pan but they never and I mean never
give her anything worthwhile to do
except cause problems for Goku and
Trunks sometimes in this Arc I ask why
is pan still tagging along Shirley Gohan
her father who was eager to help would
have an issue with his daughter putting
her life at risk like this and not only
that she causes a problem for Goku in
literally every single episode why is he
cool with her being around all the time
now don't get me wrong I love the idea
of Pat as a character but a character
needs a reason to be present and she
really doesn't she has a motivation to
be there sure but not a reason or excuse
to be there but
that brings us to the ending which on
its own is the single most fitting and
tear-jerking ending I've ever seen one
that I've seen a great number of times
prior to my watch through of this but
one that also never fails to bring a
tear to my eye perfectly encapsulating
what I love about Dragon Ball and Goku
in a few simple snapshots at the end
it's a beautiful way to end the series
and one I have never ever forgotten and
probably never will as always I've been
totally not Mark and thank you so much
for watching until we meet again
foreign
[Music]